okay yeah good question good question
why well I actually could because my
graph is good I could say it's from the
graph okay however the reason I heard is
such a simple graph is sort of that as
we look at this topic you can focus on
how this works rather than complexity of
the course you know graph this will
usually be something more complicated
and it's not so simple right do you have
to use calculus to prove it so I'm going
to show you with a simple question right
and then later on you'll be able to play
it more complex
I'm looking for a closer space that's
empty the moon okay so therefore I'm
gonna use khakis to work out so I'll say
DP on DT okay nice simple function so
what I've got here is 2t minus two okay
now in previous questions would say
something like graphs are neither
features all that kind of thing so you
might say for stationary points blah
blah blah
but stationary points are very interest
to me right if it just stops and then it
keeps on going what does that have to do
with closest or furthest okay so rather
than stationary points here I'm going to
say possible turning points okay that's
what I'm really interested in and I
can't say that Tony puts definitely
occur when the derivative is zero
because they might not it might be a
horizontal plane inflection
that's why possible or potential or some
like that so your solar
okay yeah so far so good
okay the fact that we've looked at this
before shows us that we've got this and
this is fine now usually we'd say things
like st. determine the nature the
stationary points that kind of question
is when he built it sooo this question
because I'm looking for closest so it's
very good to me if this turning point is
a maximum so I'm gonna say the second
derivative okay I'm going to use this
method rather than testing the first
derivative on either side why why this
method assume good this thing's really
easy I'm sorry this thing is very easy
to differentiate again as they're
fractions in or anything like that right
so the second derivative is 2 and
because that's a constant that is always
greater than zero so since it's greater
than zero it's concave up which means
it's a relative okay so far so good but
now we hit a snag okay at this point
usually you know in fact even in like
quadratics where you sometimes ask
what's the minimum value of such and
such or the bathroom though okay
and what we would say is find the axis
of symmetry Hakan up Aroon and your home
and host we're happy with but we
distinguish between these and the other
kind of movement and absolute motion in
the last topic before your exam right
that's not enough to say therefore this
is the minima
okay to say it's very closest I need to
show it's not just relative
it's absolutely
okay now there are three things that
stand in the way of a relative minimum
of being an absolutely three things okay
I'm gonna put them up here I'm not going
to deal with the beeps of death because
we see a few people and this is its
whole own area but I just want to tell
you what they are first okay three
different things the first one I heard
was disco taboos which is right if a
graph has breaks in it okay so for
instance so this is just an example so
do draw yourself a surprise we've worked
out this part okay we found the minimum
that's great okay but the other side of
the graph there might be something over
here okay suppose this actually went up
and there's an asymptote I know it's not
because this is a quadratic but suppose
okay and there's something else on the
other side like this okay
now we see graphs like this before so
you find this you showed me the second
derivative that it's a bit of a but it's
early a relative minimum it's only a
minimum in this area there are other
values that are less than er okay so
discontinuity is going to open us up to
the possibility that a relative minimum
might not be the absolutely okay that's
the first possible problem
ah are the stationary points or other
turning points okay so for instance we
just maybe we just found lunch the
turning point because it's a simple
graph okay but it wouldn't be that hard
to imagine okay here's one part of it
okay but if it does this and then this
okay so if the degree of your function
was a little higher you'll have more
stationary points you've got a relative
minimum and you've got another relative
minimum so then you have to decide which
one it is in that case they're both
going to be relative you'll get you know
secretary of both will be positive so
all you have to do is actually test out
the bones you've got to summon you find
what you get the P in this case and
you'll see what is higher than the other
yeah that's right yes
so discontinuities that breaks the graph
are the two new points you can either
call it boundary values or I call them
inputs now I told you just now that T is
greater than zero okay so that was the
earlier part of the graph that we were
interested in so there was a domain
restriction right domain restrictions
are very very common
we max me problems okay cuz rather than
just X or Y which is some numbers they
can just do whatever they like
okay for instance you might take a sheet
of paper okay and they say look if you
won't cut off the corners of this thing
if you cut the corners off and this is
actually a very common question you'll
see this a lot and you cut off this
square from each part okay I don't know
if you guys can see this but hold up in
a second
okay now assuming I've done this in a
reasonable fashion cut off some squares
okay and what you've got is we kind of
shape but now I can fold this so if I
fall in these edges
like I am going to guess okay so now
I've got a really shiny looking boss
okay now the question will be what will
the volume of the box been okay actually
that's not really a question the
question is what's the biggest volume
the box can be okay because it's a
finite piece of paper so I can't make a
box as big as I like right but I'm
obviously some boxes like this will be
smaller or bigger than other ones based
on the size of these squares okay so
therefore you can see in that case T's
not just greater than zero right it's
not just that that's got to be positive
there's also a limit to how big can be
it'll stop it like T's got to be or X
has got to be less than fifteen or
something like that okay so what we mean
is boundary values just want me to say
or endpoints okay the graph is going to
not go on forever let's start and stop
at very definite positions okay so let
me give an example
okay so they go I just had an almost
stationary point past another turning
point the other turning point doesn't
present a problem okay because it's a
maximum right so we're not that
interested in it but when the graph ends
alright suppose that was the end of a
domain okay even though it's not a
turning point of course it's relevant to
us because it's the closest we get means
the comment it's an accident okay so of
course this is a equals zero right and
all life ends or the dinosaurs don't
make it so you can see in this case what
am I going to have to do well if there
are other turns once you've got to test
these values see what you get the p1
will be higher oughta be Lord you pick
the lowest one okay if you're after a
minimum obviously a big highlight if you
have to relax here what are you gonna
have to do you're gonna have to test
this value okay it'll be you know three
okay but then you're also gonna have to
test both end points both ends of the
domain okay so in this case I would
actually have to test T equals zero okay
and if it ended at say five I'd have to
test T was five as well and sure enough
I might get a value that's a lot of so
that will be the real maximum okay so
there are those three problems right or
three obstacles in this case none of
them are issues so how do I conclude now
this part is a little bit tricky but
hopefully in the light of what I've
written here is so make sense okay I'm
gonna say since this is the only
stationary point okay now this is
important right because it's sort of
covering this idea here I'm saying there
are no other twenty points that I need
to be interested in and also the
function
is continuous because sure enough this
is just the parabola right there breaks
in it okay
so I can say yeah it doesn't stop and
start at any point so here I'm trying to
get away from this problem since this is
the only station point and also the
function is continuous now what would I
say to get over this right well I'd have
to say in the domain zero okay so that's
not full stop I'm still going so I'm
gonna have to say look I've covered
these endpoints I'll actually consider
them okay and I really should have
tested T equals zero up above here so
that could verify that it actually isn't
the matter that I'm interested therefore
actually I've said since already so I
don't need to say anymore since it's the
only station point and it's continuous
in this domain right the relative is
also the absolute minimum
. after that i can then conclude and I
can say I put in a sentence the question
was in the form of a sentence so my
answer ought to also need a sentence I
would say the closest the comic gets is
3000 kilometers and that occurs when
after one day